Das Folter-Ufo mit Florentin Scoville und Stefan Schmerz. Wie viele Scoville waren das jetzt? Okay, kurz dazu ein Statement. Wir haben in diesem Podcast nie gefoltert. Wir lehnen Folter ab. Es sind nur drei Tiere zu Schaden gekommen. Korrekt. Das klingt jetzt erst mal viel, aber ihr müsst überlegen, wir machen 400 Folgen plus. Richtig, auf Folge gebrochen ist das wirklich gar nichts. Das ist gar nichts. Und außerdem, die meisten von den Tieren waren nicht Wirbeltiere, die meiner persönlichen Privatmeinung auch nicht als Tiere zählen sollten, das ist meine Privatmeinung. Sondern noch unter Pflanzen. Sondern noch unter Pflanzen, vielleicht sogar unter Steinen, unter Muscheln. Was? Wirklich ganz, ganz, wirklich ganz. Wo sind Muscheln denn natürlich? Keine Wirbel, keine Chance in dieser Welt. Wer keine Wirbelsäule hat, wer nichts gerade stehen kann. Keine Wirbel, keine Rechte. Keine Wirbel, keine Rechte. Du bist nicht der Echte. Kannst nichts für was
stehen. Kannst ja nicht mal fechten.
Kannst nicht für Dinge stehen,
deswegen wirst du vergehen.
Aufrechtstehen brauchen wir.
Gerade jetzt.
Weg mit den Wirbeltieren.
Gerade jetzt in unserer jetzigen Gesellschaft
musst du gerade jetzt
mit den aktuellen Dingen
musst du gerade stehen. Also auf jeden Fall, Philipp, vielen, vielen Dank. Ja gut, die Vorwürfe der Folterreihe, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Also auf jeden Fall, Philipp, vielen, vielen Dank. Ja gut, die Vorwürfe der Folterrei, des Folterns sehen wir natürlich ungern, aber auch wir müssen uns auf den Mund gucken lassen von der Community, das ist klar. Und da müssen natürlich solche Vorwürfe auch mal im Raum stehen bleiben können. Ich finde, man muss das auch aushalten können. Wenn dir jemand die Folter vorwirft, dann musst du das auch aushalten können. Oh, das ist mein neuer Vorsatz für dieses Jahr. Aushalten lernen. Ja. Innehalten, harren. Nee, das hat niemand gesagt. Wirklich verharren. Nein, nicht verharren. Einfach wirklich verharren. Dein Vorsatz für die letzten vier Jahre ist verharren, bleiben, status quo bewahren. Ja, wirklich in Sackgassen auch mal wirklich bleiben drinstecken. Ja, liegen lassen. Auf jeden Fall. Hast du Erfahrungen mit Folter, um da mal einzusteigen? Nee, es gibt ja so in diesen Städten wie, so diesen alten bayerischen Städten, so Rotenburg ob der Tauber und so, da gibt es doch so Foltermuseen. Viel zu viele Wörter für eine kleine Stadt. Viel zu arrogant. Ein Wort pro 10.000 Einwohner, sag ich. Rotenburg ob der Tauber an der Isar bei Osnabrück. Rotenburg, da gibt es doch so ein Foltermuseum. Der kann eben alle von Rotenburg jetzt auch, oder? Ja. Was ist denn da los bei denen in Rotenburg, oder? Ich weiß nicht, fett. Aber da so, da in diesem Süddeutschland, alte Burgen, bla bla bla, verorte ich so Foltermuseen. Ja. Da wollte ich immer mal gerne rein, mir das mal angucken und sagen, so Kopfschütteln daneben stehen und sagen. Nee, das sollte man nicht tun. Also das sollte man wirklich hinter sich lassen. Die Gruppe mit diesem Führer, der da durchgeht und einem das so erklärt, die sind schon viel weiter.
Aber man steht da neben und will den so gefallen, der Gruppe, und sagt so, ich finde, man sollte das nicht machen.
Du bist zurückgeblieben, du bist stecken geblieben, du bist inne gehalten.
Lass die Leute zurück, lass mich zurück.
Ich meine, eine beliebte Foltermethode, oder ja, wir können eine Top-rei-Foltermethoden einfach mal, würde ich auf jeden Fall. Schlafentzug. Wapadabada rumpadam padada dingelilingeliling, die das Podcast-Ufo, Top-Drei-Foltermethoden. Genf mal gerade weghören, bitte. Schlafentzug auf jeden Fall. Schlafentzug habe ich erlebt an der Katze meiner Mitbewohnerin. Die Katze meiner Mitbewohnerin hat mich gefoltert, denn Schlafentzug ist eine anerkannte Foltermethode. Eben nicht. Und zwar, doch ist es die sogenannte weisse Folter, die keine Spuren hinterlässt, ist eine anerkannte Foltermethode von der UNESCO-Weltkulturerbeaktion Mensch sonderlos mit sechs Zahlen bist du dabei. Warum bist du bei Lotto? Warum hält die Ersatz bei dir bei Lotto? Lotto, Toto, sechs aus neunundvierzig, super Zahl. So, und da wurde nämlich anerkannt, dass Schlafentzug eine Foltermethode ist und damit wurde ich von der Katze meiner Mitbewohnern gefoltert, denn die hat regelmäßig in mein Bett uriniert und mich somit vom Schlafen abgehalten. Was rückblickend deine Folter, die du dann an der Katze ausgeübt hast, als Notwehr wirken lässt. Notfolter. Das heißt, was, Stefan, du kennst dich aus, welche juristischen Möglichkeiten habe ich jetzt gegen diese Katze vorzugehen? Also was habe ich dafür, welche Türen stehen mir sperrangelweit offen? Ich denke an Harry Potter. Ich denke an Harry Potter Teil 3 der Hippo. Und dafür bist du einer der bestbezahlten Anwälte Deutschlands, dass du auf solche Ideen kommst. So, wir machen die, wir wenden die Hippograif-Taktik an, okay? Wir denken an Harry Potter Teil drei. Und dafür bist du einer der bestbezahlten Anwälte Deutschlands, dass du auf solche Ideen kommst.
So, wir machen die, wir wenden die Hippogreif-Taktik an, okay? Wir denken an Harry Potter, Draco wird angegriffen vom Hippogreifen, Cedric, Hedric, Hagrid, Hedric, Hedric hat nicht zugeguckt, gehört, Hippogreif geht auf Draco Malfoy los. Der sagt, wenn das mein Vater erfährt, dementsprechend sagt deinem Vater Bescheid. Das sehen wir nicht, das ist impliziert. Dieses Gespräch, das wurde rausgeschnitten. Aber das wäre jetzt mein Vorschlag von BBS-Liga aus Köln. Senior Cuaroden hat das rausgeschnitten und gesagt, das müssen wir nicht sehen.
Er hat gesagt, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Die Leute müssen das nicht sehen.
Was sie nicht sehen, kann wirken.
Und dann war es raus.
Ja, das brauchen wir nicht anstrengen, Herr Cuaron.
Das war nur eine einfache Frage, Herr Cuaron.
Die standen alle schon bei.
Pardoname, Herr Cuaron.
Tom Felton stand schon da, wollte drehen, hatte das Skript in der Hand, hat gesagt, so.
Und Alfonso hat gesagt, no, nichts mit mir. Das muss wieder gehen. Und dann wurde es nicht gedreht. Deswegen, wie kannst du dich rächen an der Katze? Rede mit deinem Vater, dann landet die Katze vor Gericht. Mein Vater wird davon erfahren. Der Henker kommt, die Todstrafe wird ausgesprochen für die Katze. dann rettet Hermine mit dem Timeturner die Katze. Genau, indem sie, Moment, zugleich, Jura ist immer so ein Kopfknoten. Ja, Jura ist ganz einfach, also, es gibt verschiedene Zeitreisemechaniken. Sie weist sich selbst darauf hin, als Zukunfts-Ich weist das Vergangenheits-ergangenheits-Hermine-Ich-Hin ... Gedankenstütze Tenet.
Nein, also, ich hasse diese Wortkombination.
Gedankenstütze Tenet.
Stütze dich niemals auf Tenet, du wirst stürzen.
Prison of Azkaban ist gleich Tenet,
was die inhärente Zeitreise angeht.
What happened, happened.
Wenn wir, wenn Hermine die Katze
mal vor dem Tod gerettet hat, hat sie die
in allen Timelines, das ist ein Closed Loop,
bis sie sich selber wieder einholt.
Okay. Das Ding ist, normalerweise, wenn man
sagt, mein Vater wird davon erfahren,
dann ist es deswegen wirksam, weil der Vater Kontakte
hat. Ich glaube, bei meinem Vater wäre das dann
das Ende der Kommunikation. Also klar,
ich kann meinem Vater davon erzählen,
aber der erzählt das dann nicht weiter an
mächtige Freunde in der Regierung. Du meinst, er würde dann nicht
seine Mächte spielen
Vielen Dank. das Ende der Kommunikation. Also klar, ich kann meinem Vater davon erzählen, aber der erzählt das dann nicht weiter an mächtige Freunde in der Regierung. Du meinst, er würde dann nicht
seine Mächte spielen lassen?
Ich glaube, nein. Ich glaube, es würde wirklich einfach da
aufhören. Also wo es bei Lucius
Malfoy, dem Vater von Draco Malfoy, in einen
grossen Baum der Verantwortung und
Korruption in der Staatsgefüge geht,
würde es bei mir einfach schlicht aufhören
in einer Sackgasse und damit enden.
Und ich weiss nicht, ob damit wirklich viel erreicht wurde und die Katze wirklich ihre Lektion lernt.
Ja, also, was ich auch spannend finde bei Harry Potter ist, dass Draco Malfoy ja der coole, jockige Bully ist.
Also wenn man so Highschool-Klischees anwendet, ist er ja der Bully, der den Nerd wegschlägt, gegen den Spinnen drückt und so weiter. You name it. Aber der Satz, wenn mein Vater davon erfährt, ist ja denkbar uncool. Weil das ja kein so Bully-Satz. Also wenn du die Hilfe, dann ist so renn doch zu Mama. Richtig. Ah, da vielleicht der Unterschied, Unterschied, renn doch zu Mama und mein Vater wird davon erfahren. Ja, das ist natürlich auch ein Unterschied im Machtgefüge, das müssen wir natürlich auch immer wieder ankreiden. Wir hören nicht auf, das anzukreiden. Wir hören hier, wir sind die Letzten, die noch aufhören, Dinge anzukreiden. Das wisst ihr von uns, das ist die Podcast-UFO-Garantie. Ja, aber soweit ich weiß, ist die Katze weiterhin auf freiem Fusse. Ich glaube, ich habe mal irgendeinen Social-Media-Post meiner Mitbewohnern gesehen, wo sie die Katze geprankt hat. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie das auf dem Internationalen Gerichtshof funktioniert. Katzenpranken ist, glaube ich, nach Unnestowelt, Kulturschutz, Aktion, Menschenrecht. Ist das eine angemessene Strafe für Folter? Ich weiß nicht genau. Pranks? Ob Prank die klassische, also ich weiß nicht, ob nach klassischen, ich weiß nicht, ob nach Abu Ghraib da einige Leute zurecht geprankt wurden, die da der Folter überführt wurden, aber so wie ich das mitbekommen habe, es gibt nämlich diesen beliebten Tierprank, der durchaus grausam ist, darf man hier sagen, vielleicht auch schon Folter, sind Pranks Folter, das werfe ich auf und lasse das dabei. Genau, du machst deinen Vater, du nimmst Dinge wahr und dann sind die weg. Genau, das ist
ein Frisbee im Park, ich werfe ihn
und ich drehe mich um, die Sekunde, die er
meine Hand verlässt, drehe ich mich um und
fahre mit dem Bus nach Hause. Vergesst das Spiel. Ob der landet,
wo der landet, ob den jemand aufgreift,
das ist dann nicht mehr meine Verantwortung. Nein.
Und zwar hat sie ihrer
Katze vorgetäuselt,
gut, ich bin
in eine andere Richtung gegangen, nein, hat ihrer Katze vorgesäuselt. Gut, ich bin in eine andere Richtung gegangen. Nein. Hat ihrer Katze vorgesäuselt. Es war ein ... Es ist schwer, das zurückzuführen. Ich habe nur die Bruchstücke gesehen. Da habe ich schon lange drüber reden. Wir können auch aufhören, weil das schon lange Thema ist. Stopp, stopp, stopp. Es ist ein bekanntes Prankformat, und zwar es sind Gummikörperteile im Spiel. ein Finger, ein Kunstfinger, ein Fakefinger.
So, der wird der Katze hingehalten, die Katze greift fröhlich zu im spielerischen Sinne, aber dann reisst ihn ab, die Katze denkt, ach du Jemini, heiliges Kanonenrohr, jetzt hab ich meinem Frauchen, bei Neuen Leben, bei Anubis, Habe ich jetzt an meinem geliebten Frauchen den Finger abgerissen. Der ist natürlich effektvoll ... Warum reden die so? Max und Moritz. Wer hat das nochmal geschrieben? Max Herre? Ich weiß es nicht. Herr Grimm hat dann tatsächlich den Finger entfernt mit effektvollem Ketchupgespritze. Und die Katze denkt, ach du Liebeslottchen, was habe ich hier angerichtet? Warum reden die Katzen in deinem Kopf? Und das sagt sehr viel über dein Katzenbild aus. Ja, okay, muss ich mir gefallen lassen. Auch diesen Vorwurf muss ich mir gefallen lassen. Ja, du lässt dir heute alles gefallen. Und zwar, in Interessen die Katze natürlich im Schock denkt, sie hätte einen unwiederbringlichen Körperschaden angerichtet. Am Ende wird das Ganze humoristisch locker aufgeklärt. So, das habe ich mitbekommen durch einen Instagram-Post. Man erklärt der Katze dann, ah, im Übrigen ... Genau, man enthüllt den Finger und sagt, hier, zähl noch mal durch, uno, due, drei, cuatro, cinque, und dann hat man alle fünf Finger noch ein.
Da setzt so viel voraus.
Absolut. Ich glaube, der Prank ist bei Hunden gängiger. Bei Hunde tatsächlich irgendwie checken, scheiße, jetzt habe ich zu krass gespielt oder was auch immer. Ich glaube, du kannst Hunde nachhaltig verstören, weil die nicht viel verstehen, wenn man dem Hund aus meinem Leben, wenn man da einen Tennisball versteckt und er sieht,
wo ich den verstecke,
sucht er danach eine halbe Stunde nach diesem
Tennisball, weil er nach dem Kommando
Such nicht mehr
Ursache, Wirkung, keine Zusammenhänge
mehr in seinem Kopf existieren.
Ich verstehe auch nicht, wie er
dann mit dem Wort Such
wohl versteht, den Tennisball zu suchen.
Das ist alles klar. Aber es ist so, das Klarste, wo ich den denn versteckt habe, vor seinen Augen wohlgemerkt, ich verstecke mich dann nicht, weil ich gehe nicht um die Ecke. Er sieht, dass ich ihn ins Regal lege, er geht nicht ins Regal, er geht ins Bad. Und das wird ich verstanden. Die Diametrall, aber vielleicht ist der Hund auch schlau genug, um zu wissen, dass er jetzt ein kleines Theaterstück aufführen soll, eine Posse, die den Mensch belustigt und er soll jetzt hier schnüffeln und suchen. Er weiß ganz genau, wo der Ball ist, ja, aber er ist halt so, ah, die wollen die Nummer wieder sehen. Ach gut, ich bin natürlich auch der Beste, das ist der Klassiker, die Suchnummer. Okay, gebt denen, was sie wollen, okay, wo ist der Ball, wo ist der Ball, wo ist der Ball? So, ich glaube, Hunde sind ... Du sagst ... Ich bin jetzt anders. Der 25er-Florentin ist auf der anderen Seite. Ich sage, Hunde sind krasser als wir. Krasser als wir. Du sagst, die führen ein Irrspiel auf. Richtig. Eine Posse. Eine Posse. Es gibt von Thomas Mann dieses herrliche Idyll, ich glaube, Herr und Hund heißt das, wo er über seinen Hund Bauschahn erzählt. Das ist wirklich absolut fantastisch. Thomas Mann, Nobelpreisträger für Literatur, schreibt ja wirklich wunderbar. Und er schreibt in diesem Buch, das ist ein ganz kleines Buch, was wirklich die Genrebezeichnung nicht Roman, nicht Novelle, sondern Idyll hat und schreibt darüber über seinen Hund Bauschahn.
Und da erzählt er, wie der ist und wie er über seinen Hund redet. Das ist absolut lustig, das ist wundervoll. Stell dir vor, du schreibst was und irgend so ein Reich-Ranitzki-Professor kriegt das vorgelegt und sagt, das ist so neu. Wir müssen eine neue Gattungsbezeichnung für diesen Text uns ausdenken. Das ist keine Posse, das ist kein Limerick. Und bei Gott, es ist keine Anekdote. Es ist ein Idyll. Es ist ein Erotik-Thriller. Es ist Schmutz, es ist Abschaum. Aber das ist doch wirklich fantastisch. Ich meine, Thomas Mann ist alt, lange tot, aber da hat er trotzdem schaut auf eine lange Literaturgeschichte zurück. Chaucer, Dickens, die haben ja auch schon was zu Papier gebracht, aber trotzdem schreibt er was, wo man sagt, nee, das ist nochmal was ganz Neues. Wahnsinn, ja. Kurzer historischer Funfact. Wir haben jetzt alle gelacht. Ich bin bereit zu lachen. Wir haben gelacht über diese Beobachtungen von Florentin. Jetzt kommt der uncoole Wissensteil, der die Pointe kaputt macht. Okay. Kannst du kurz sagen, bis wann die Leute skippen sollen? Einfach kurz als Servicefaktor. Ich mach's ganz schnell. Er hat es selber Idyll genannt. Okay? Er hat einfach, das ist wirklich so, er hat einfach selber da Idyll drunter geschrieben. Moment, das geht. Du kannst selbst, also auch wenn du wirklich Bock normalen Roman. Komm mal kurz in die Ecke. Du kannst machen, was du willst. Wie, aber du meintest doch es gibt. Du denkst so eng, du denkst so eng. Ah, jemand muss mir dann Roman, Novelle, Idyll draufschreiben. Ah, Krass, jemand anderes muss mir diese Genre-Bezeichnung.
Nein, aber du meintest doch, es gibt Gesetze.
Du meintest doch, es gibt Regeln.
Siehst du dieses Regelbuch hier? Siehst du das?
Ja, ich sehe es.
Nee, im Müll. Ich glaube es nicht. Ich habe es im Müll geworfen.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Das Regelbuch ist jetzt im Müll. Eimer.
Das heißt, du kannst einen wirklich Rotottstandard-Roman schreiben.
Wirklich mit unerwartetem Beginn,
mit Informationen, die dem Leser
vorbehalten wird. Mit erwartetem Ende,
mit unerwartetem Beginn und erwartetem Ende.
Mit Rap-Teil in der Mitte, mit Gutschein,
Coupons gegen Ende nochmal.
Drei leeren Seiten, um draufzuschreiben,
für eure Gedanken.
Dann ist eine Seite ein Spiegel, wo draufsteht,
aber das Schönste ist auf dieser Seite. Oder so, also ein Schwachsinn. Also wirklich jeder kennt diesen Roman, hat zwanzig davon gelesen. Und dann schreibe ich aber Der Engel und der Zwerg. Ein Verwirrspiel. Und plötzlich alle Literaturwissenschaftler so, darf er das? Canst he das? Ist das möglich? Is this by whom it be possible? Und dann hast du einfach mal so Larifari, Lirum, Larum, ein neues Literaturgenre erschaffen aus dem Nichts. Ein Larifari, ein Larifari-Roman. Finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Der Knirr und die Milch, ein Larifari, was wir in den Willen Ein Larifari. Und dann lass die Professoren mal rauchen, oben in den Reklam-Türmen, oben im gelben Turm, auf Stockwerk 110 aufwärts. Die Reklam-Türme. Da qualmt's, da siehst du aus den hohen Fenstern. Die Schornsteine. Man denkt, das ist eine Fabrik, aber die Schornsteine, das ist eigentlich ein Abzug. Denkfabrik, ja. Die qualmen und qualmen und wo sollen wir das einordnen, Kategorisierung, Ist das noch barock, ist das Sturm und Drang, wo gehört das hin, das Larifari? Die Wecklam. Ja, kannst du machen. Im weitesten Sinne mein Neffe schreibt super gerne Geschichten. Ähnlich wie wir es hier hatten. Ah ja, cool. Kindergeschichten. Genau, schlieg. Da wollte ich ihn auch schon mal vors Mikro zerren, indem ich ihm die wegreisse, aus seinen kleinen Händen, schmutzigen Händen reisse und hier vorlese einfach und ihm den Gespött als Larifari preisgebe. Habe ich noch nicht gemacht, werde ich auch nie vielleicht machen, aber das ist sehr spannend, weil der wie du gerade Dinge, die es gibt und Wörter, die man kennt, benutzt in seinem Kontext. Zum Beispiel kennt er es auch ab und zu in Köln, sieht Köln und dann gibt es den grossen Kosmos, über den er schreibt, der spielt auf dem Kölnberg. Und es ist alles so ähnlich, es ist alles so immer, es ist sehr nah dran und doch was ganz eigenes.
Und mir gefallen deswegen die Reklam-Türme sehr. Ich finde die Reklam-Türme, man hat, man weiss genau, was gemeint ist, die sind richtig hoch. Und richtig gelb. Richtig fucking gelb. Sonnengelb. Wie kriegen die die so gelb? Ja, liebe ich. Und da qualmt's raus. Finde ich ich gut. Aus den Denkfabriken der Reklamheft. Finde ich richtig gut. Ich mag ja die leeren Seiten und Bücher am liebsten so. Ich finde, wenn du so ein Buch anfängst. Du machst Notizbücher. Na, ja, auch. Aber wenn du so ein Buch anfängst und du hast erst mal drei Seiten Widmung, du denkst dir, geil, ich komm hier gut voran, ich mach wirklich, ich mach Strecke, ich blätter, ich blätter, ich blätter, geil. Und wenn dann auf Seite sieben der erste Satz kommt, du denkst dir, so jetzt erst mal einen Tee.
So jetzt mach ich erst mal einen Tee, jetzt erst mal Entspannung, Beine hochlesen, ich hab heute schon gut was geschafft.
So und dann wird's zäh, leider, das finde ich, Bücher machen da leider oft den Fehler, dass es dann halt sehr zäh wird.
Du bist ja so gewollt belesen und so interessiert.
Liest du, also das wäre eine Frage, zwei Fragen sogar, Bücher in der Originalsprache oder auf Deutsch?
Also, du kannst nicht so viele Sprachen fließen, deswegen. Nee, aber englische Bücher auf Englisch oder auf Deutsch. Also, du kannst nicht so viele Sprachen fließen, deswegen. Englische Bücher auf Englisch oder auf Deutsch lesen. Ist das okay? Ja, wenn es geht Englisch, ja, ja, das schon. Hä? Ist das nicht, aber bei Film verstehe ich das sehr, aber bei guten Besetzungen, okay. Du hast Wortspiele drin und musst da gucken, wie es ist und es ist ja auch eine gute Übung, finde ich. Ich habe damals tatsächlich, weil ich besser werden wollte in Englisch, habe ich ein Buch gelesen, Zen and the Art of Motorcycle Maintenance, ein Klassiker, was gute Bücher Motorcycle Maintenance angeht und den habe ich komplett auf Englisch laut vorgelesen. Ich habe ein komplettes Buch laut vorgelesen, einfach weil ich besser in Englisch werden wollte und das hat Spaß gemacht gemacht. Man kommt da gut durch und es hat irgendwie was. Und es ist auch eine andere Leseerfahrung, etwas einfach vorzulesen, weil du musst dir Gedanken machen, wie du Dinge vorliest. Wo ist die Betonung? Alles falsch vorgelesen. Alles falsch vorgelesen, natürlich, welche Figur spricht gerade. Weil oft hast du ja das Problem, dass du was liest, aber du liest es so weg, es flimmert so durch die Gegend und du hast keine Ahnung, was du liest.
Geht nicht, wenn du vorliest.
The Tyre of the Motorcycle.
Boards.
Und dann kam es zu diesem
komischen Moment, wo
in Florentinstrasse an der kalten
Novembernacht jemand liegen blieb mit
seinem Motorcycle und dachte, ich bin verloren,
ich bin mitten in Bayern hier irgendwo,
Ebersberg, niemand spricht meine Sprache, niemand kann mir hier mein Motorcycle reparieren und die Familie will, weil Florentin immer laut vorgelesen durchs Wohnzimmer gelaufen ist.
Ah, ist es der Keilriemen oder sind es die Schwabotzen?
Und wie ein Boxenstopp, nach zwei Minuten die Wills schwirrten um das Motorcycle herum, fuhr er wieder von dannen.
Gemaintenced.
Ein Märchen. Ein Wintermärchen. Ein Herbstmärchen. Ein Herbstmärchen. Ein Herbstmärchen. Okay. Und zweite Frage ist Prolog, nee, Vorwort lesen oder nicht? Nein, fuck Vorwort. Ja, fuck der Vorwort. Ey, ich finde, Vorwörter sind also das Krasseste der Welt, weil dafür wirst du ja Literaturwissenschaftler, oder? Also das ist ja dann dein täglich Brot. Und ich finde vor allem bei so wirklich monumentalen, epochalen Büchern das Vorwort zu schreiben. Also, Herr Tietze, Sie haben jetzt schon einige Romane verfasst, Sie sind eine bekannte Größe in der Welt der Literatur. Gut, die grossen Preise sind Ihnen noch verwehrt worden, aber das muss nicht immer was heißen.
Wem es um Preise geht, der ist in dem Beruf des Schreiberlings.
Nein, dann verstehen Sie mich nicht falsch.
Wer ein Mann der Worte ist, der hat mit den Preisen nichts, der muss mit Preisen nicht in die Bredouille kommen, wenn man spricht. Es ist ein Genuss, Ihnen zuzuhören, aber Sie müssen gar nicht weiterreden. Es ist ja meiner Meinung nach fast sogar ein Adelsschlag, ein Ritterschlag, ein ... Es ist ja fast schon ein Interior-Reklam-Türm. Wir schreiben, wir sind Autoren, keine Sprecher. Nein, nein, nein. Ich finde, es ist ja fast schon ein Ritterschlag, wenn man von den Kritiken ... Und da muss ich sagen, wenn man Ritterschlag oder Rittersport. So, und jetzt haben wir tatsächlich einen Auftrag bekommen, und sie sollen ein Vorwort schreiben. Ah. Für eine Neuauflage. Also ein bekanntes Buch ist schon seit ein paar Jährchen unterwegs. Die wollen jetzt eine Neuauflage machen. Klett-Kotter und wie gesagt, wir vermitteln sie da gerne. Die Bibel. Also die Bibel, die haben sich da was vorgestellt, so 18 Seiten. 18 Seiten? Ja, wirklich einfach mal als Vorwort, wirklich mal so historkontextuell einbinden, irgendwie Wirkungsgeschichte, halt so ein paar Stichpunktenhafte. Ja, genau. Bis Montag, wenn es geht. Bis Montag? Genau, wie gesagt, die wollen leider wirklich raus, die wollen das Weihnachtsgeschäft noch mitnehmen und deswegen bräuchten das relativ schnell. Weihnachtsgeschäft bei den Bibeln mitnehmen. Sie glauben nicht, wie viele Bibeln. Man sollte meinen, dass wenn man Weihnachten feiert, man die Bibel schon mal zu Hause hat. Dachte ich auch. Nein, nein, nein. Und in Bottrop werden drei neue Hotels eröffnet, und sie wissen, wie viele Bibeln da über die Theke gehen. Man sagt, auf jedem Flur, 20 Zimmer. In jedem Zimmer. Genau, 20 Zimmer pro Flur. Wie viele Flur, wie hoch sind die?
Lassen Sie mich, ich lasse nämlich
2012, 2015,
mit reiem Sinn,
die Qualmenden Schornsteine.
Ja, irgendwer muss
Vorwörter schreiben, die werden nicht gelesen.
Meiner Meinung nach Vorwörter auch
skippen, da habe ich nämlich das Gefühl,
ich habe schon was getan.
Man ist auf Seite 9 schon und denkt sichippen, da habe ich nämlich das Gefühl, ich habe schon was getan. Man ist auf Seite neun schon und
denkt sich, wow, ich lese dir was weg, hat
das Vorwort. Kannst du wegblättern mit
ah, das lese ich danach. Keine
Spoiler. Ich will mich jetzt nicht spoilern lassen, lese ich
danach als Kontextualisierung, aber
das finde ich schon krass, dass irgendjemand sich hinsetzt
mit einem leeren, weissen
Bildschirm und sagt so
Bi
äh wo fangen wir an, äh, ich bin schon die richtige Person, die das schreiben soll, das schon, das schon, das schon, nee, nee, nee, da mache ich mir gar keine Sorgen, vier Evangelien, oh, top, machen wir mal, welche würde ich auf, welche würde ich auf vier, welche würde ich auf eins setzen?
Klar, Lukas, das ist klar, aber welche auf zwei?
Ich glaube, ich mache mir erstmal einen Tee.
Ja, guten Tag, Herr Herr am Apparat.
Ja, Professor Steglitz, wir wollten mal fragen, wie es aussieht mit dem Vorwort. Das ist ja in drei Tagen fertig. Das ist so gut wie fertig. Das ist so gut wie fertig. Ja, ja, ich bin jetzt am Feinschliff, da müssen nur noch ein paar, also ein paar Fussnoten oder so, ein paar Quellenangaben, aber das habe ich alles da, das habe ich alles hier. Das steht, nee, nee, das ist kein Problem. Wir zählen auf Sie. Ja, ja, ja, nee, das steht. Wir vertrauen Ihnen, wir zählen auf Sie. Ja, das habe ich alles hier. Das steht. Wir zählen auf Sie. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, nee, das steht.
Wir vertrauen ihm.
Wir zählen auf Sie.
Ja, absolut. Nein, das ist kein Problem.
So sicher wie die Maus in der Kirche.
Scheiße.
Lieber Gott, bitte hilf mir.
Was hast, willst du nicht das Vorwort schreiben?
War das Neue Testament das Vorwort schreiben?
War das Neue Testament das Vorwort zum Alten Testament oder andersrum, weiss man nicht. Oder halt das Mormonen-Ding, ne?
Bei Mormonen gibt es ja drittes, dritter Teil.
Die Mormonen sind der dritte Part, ja.
Das ist schon geil.
Also das finde ich auch konsequent zu sagen.
Und Scientology ist der vierte Part.
In gewisser Weise, aber ich finde es auch konsequent, dass Gott sagt, ja, ich hau mal raus an mein Wissen. Ja, irgendwie checken die das noch nicht ganz, die bringen sich leider gegenseitig um. Komm, mach mal noch mal Jesus, der schickt das um. So, jetzt zweitausend Jahre Stille und dann sagen, nee, jetzt Teil drei, jetzt geben wir den Amis noch mal Teil drei. Bisschen wie George R.R., lass mal laufen, und dann aber was raushaut. Glaubst du, Martin vervollständigt die Serie noch? Das weiss ich nicht, ist mir auch ganz egal. Das weisst du nicht? Ist dir das wirklich egal? Ist mir egal, wie Game of Fucking Thrones ist. Wirklich? Naja, es heißt ja Song of Ice and Fire. Game of Thrones ist ja nur der Name des ersten Bandes. House of Them Dragons. Ist ja nur der Name des ersten Buchs. Und dann so wurde die Serie benannt. Aber eigentlich heißt es ja Song of Earth and Fire, weil es geht ja letzten Endes um das Widerspiel von Feuer und Eis in verschiedenen Manifestationen. Also es gibt verschiedene Prophezeiungen, die letzten Endes eine Gezeitenwende-Ankündigung. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, welche der verschiedenen Figuren spielt jetzt in welche Prophezeiungen Archetypen hinein, also der welche Teil der Prophezeiung erfüllen soll. Und da gibt es ja noch viele Lücken.
Ich habe dich eigentlich nur noch deinem Sternzeichen gefragt.
Krebs! Eskrebs?
Eskrebs?
Oh, ich hab jetzt eine Sonnenuhr gesehen.
Eine Sonnenuhr, ich stand immer mit eindruckender Anblick,
Sonnenuhr an der Häuserwand, also wirklich
eine Metallstange, die wirklich gegen jede
Sicherheitsvorschrift einfach aus der
Häuserwand raus
starrt und
dann aber, aufgefächert,
die
Mondzeichen, Sternzeichen.
So, und dann
konntest du also jeder Stunde des Tages ein Sternzeichen zuordnen. Also anscheinend gibt es auch noch eine Aufteilung des Tages in Sternzeichen, was mir unbekannt war. Also dass du einfach nur sagst, ah, acht Uhr, weder. Ja, deswegen hast du ja einen Aszendent, musst du für den Aszendenten ja deine Tageszeit, deine Geburtszeit angeben.
Ich, 13.30, habe einen Aszendent, musst du für den Aszendenten ja deine Tageszeit, deine Geburtszeit angeben. Ich, 13.30, habe im Aszendenten am 5. August den Skorpion. 13.30, wow, 13.30 wurdest du geboren. Wann gehen da die Wehen los, ne, dann in der Nacht oder was? Wie lange dauern Wehen? Schon lange, schon lange. Also kommt drauf an, ne, aber es ist schon 13.30, boah, hat deine Mutter geschlafen die Nacht überhaupt oder war das wirklich ein kompletter? Du bist gerade super interessiert, also du bist so tief, willst du jetzt einsteigen, hörst du gar nicht vor. Wahnsinn. Und da warst du im Bauch drin oder was? Im Bauch war niemand. Also du, nee, aber jetzt mal ohne Scheiß, also du warst volle Lotte im Bauch. Ja, ich. Ja, ich glaub schon, ja, du auch, also. Komplett drin. Ja, alles von mir. Also wirklich drin und dann wirklich alles drin. Alles von mir. Also nicht so wie beim Bett, wo man manchmal so ein Bein raussteckt, irgendwie zur Abkühlung oder so. Du warst wirklich volle Tippitoppi-Paletti, du warst einfach puff, puff, ich bin drin. Okay, Soundeffekte. Kopfüber oder was? Weiß ich nicht. Kopfüber warst du drin? Ist das ein Hörspiel? Ist das so ein Hörspiel für Kinder, wo sie lernen, wie die Geburt funktioniert? Und hast du dir gedacht so, what the fuck, alles Kopf über? Oder war dir das scheiße? Nein, ich erinnere mich nicht. Warum bist du da jetzt so investiert? Und dann hast du gar nichts gesehen oder so rot, so von aus? Ich glaube rot. Rot oder was? Ich glaube ein bisschen rot. Alter, krasser Scheiss. Mann, wir müssen uns mal häufiger unterhalten. Du hast so viele geile Storys, was du alles erlebt hast, ey, im fucking Bauch, Alter. Du bist so geil, ey, echt schade. Mensch, ey, wir kennen uns schon so lange und irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, wir haben uns noch gar nicht richtig unterhalten. Jetzt geht mein Berndesatz in meine Nase. Berndesatz ist meine Nase. Du hast dich so fein genossen. Wirklich, ich hätte dich kein Nase in Erinnerung. Die Schweine haben mir die Nase zugemacht. Die da oben, oder was? Weil ich bin, genau, also Technik. Ich arbeite als Techniker. Geil, ey, krass. Und dann, also wenn du sagst, Geburt, was genau, also wie lief das ab? Also was war da? Wenn Freunde sich auf die falschen Dinge fokussiert. Ich bin Elektrotechniker. Ach krass, aber jetzt mal ohne Scheiß. Wollen wir nicht lieber über unseren Beruf reden? Ich merke, du saugst immer Luft ein durch den Mund. Machst du das ständig oder ist das irgendwie so ein ... Ja, hä, atmen. Ach, krass, atmen. Okay, und also warum machst du da? Ist das so ein Tick oder was? Ja, ist ein A-Tick, ja. Ach, krass. Das Angeborene Angewinnung, machst du auch. Aber wie kommt die Luft dann wieder raus? Also saug du dich dann langfristig voll mit Luft oder was? Krass,
ich habe ganz vergessen, dass ich nach Hause muss wieder.
What the fuck, was heißt
Hause? Dass ich deine Nummer löschen muss.
Du wohnst in einem Haus? What the fuck?
Ich habe ganz vergessen, dass ich dich nie wiedersehen will.
Ah, habe ich gerade ganz vergessen.
Lasst eure Mitmenschen nicht alleine. Eine Mitteilung des ... Wir wissen es gerade selber. Eine Mitteilung für ... Wir haben es leider selber gleich. Nehmt euch ein Herz. Nächstenliebe. Nehmt euch ein Herz. Miserium. Ah, ist das das Vorwort für die Bibel? Ja. Geil. Bibel bin ich nicht bibelfest, weiß ich nicht so viel drüber, ich kenne die, das können wir eigentlich machen, so die besten Bibelstories mal einmal besprechen, Noah und der Wal, Johannes der Täufer. Wie kriegt der Luft im Wal, ne? Der muss ja irgendwie, also der Wal selber atmet ja durchs Loch. Das heißt, der Wal taucht auf, atmet einmal tief ein durch sein Loch. Wo ist dann die Luft? Lunge, Wahllunge. Das heißt, Noah muss vom Mund irgendwie die Lunge gefunden haben. Und dann einfach rein, da hat er von innen die Lunge aufgemacht oder was? Wie so ein Luftballon, wo man einmal so diesen, einmal aufmacht. Ja, wie Lachgas, die in dem Spiegel hat. Die kennt ihr euch jetzt an, dass man sagt, Noah sich luftgut. Wie bei Helium atmet man einmal ein und dann geht, krass, ne? Ich hätte neulich ja diese Obama-Doku geguckt, über unsere Ozeane, wie er spricht.
Our vast oceans. Als säße er vor mir. So, und dann erzählt er da, und da habe ich nochmal darüber nachgedacht, wie Dokus funktionieren, und ich glaube, das ist doch alles, und das ist eine offene Frage, aber das ist doch alles Bullshit, oder? Ja, absolut. Weil dann kommen ja so Storylines wie
ähm,
keine Ahnung, Robbe,
Robbenfamilie, das Kleine muss dringend mal wieder essen, aber es ist schwierig, auch Orcas fischen diese Meere leer. Okay, Barrack, wir müssen einmal noch mal einen neuen Take hier machen. Ja, ja, aber du verstehst. Ja. So, und dann filmen die angeblich diese Robbe, Barack, wir müssen einmal noch mal einen neuen Take hier machen. Aber du verstehst. So, und dann filmen die angeblich diese Robbe, diesen Robbenvater, den wir gerade etabliert haben.
Natürlich haben die Stuntdubels, klar.
Dann machst du so ein Total und du siehst tausend Robben.
Und dann wollte er mir erzählen, dass diese eine Robbe ...
Ja, aber sorry, genau, denke ich auch, aber dann denke ich mir auch, das ist ja ... Die haben ja schon eine journalistische Sorgfaltspflicht.
Die können ja nicht dann irgendwie behaupten ...
Also, gibt's Robbenforscher, die sich diese Doku angucken und denken,
ja, das sind andere, die so ...
Ja, die das sehen.
Die das erkennen.
Die das sehen.
Ich als Robbenleihe erkenne jetzt nicht, ob das einfach Lug und Betrug ist.
Da wird auch geschnitten.
Ich weiß, dass er fucking geschnitten ist. Nee, pass mal auf.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Du musst es mal auf.
Ich würde die unerwenden Scheiß.
Komm mal auf.
Eine Sache, ich glaube nämlich, es ist andersrum.
Ich glaube, die
haben irgendeinen coolen Moment.
Robbe fängt Fisch.
Und dann sagen die, ah, die Robbe filmen wir jetzt weiter und schneiden das dann aber davor.
Ja, aber wenn die eine weiss ist und die andere schwarz ist, geht das ja nicht.
Ja, nee, das geht nicht. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass du erst die Robbe verfolgst, bis sie was frisst.
Sondern du schaust, ah, wir legen da einen Fisch hin, eine Robbe frisst den und dann filmen wir die
und dann erzählen wir, die Robbe ist hungrig.
Schau dir an, wie hungrig sie ist.
Hast du jemals eine Doku geguckt?
Hast du jemals eine
Fisch? Wir hören mal rein, wie der Magen knurrt.
Schau mal, wie gut
diese Robbe aussieht. Guck mal, wie hungrig sie ist.
Lieber was weissen.
Stopp dir gerne deine Chips rein.
Die Robbe hätte jetzt auch gerne deine Fettchips hier.
Oh, noch ein Kinderbeinung?
Wirklich noch ein Kinderbeinung?
Nur weil sechs in der Packung sind,
heißt das nicht, dass du dir auch sechs alle in deine Futterluke reinstopfen sollst, du Fettschmein.
Florentin, beist du aus wie dieses Walross hier.
Naja.
Moment mal, hat der gerade meinen Namen gesagt?
Schiebt sich den Fisch in den Mund.
Sorry, aber hat der gerade meinen Namen gesagt?
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Fisch.
Lecker Fisch. Walross ist Fischen. Sorry, aber hat der gerade meinen Namen, hat der gerade meinen Namen gesagt? Das kann ja nicht sein. Fisch, mhm, lecker Fisch, Walrus ist Fisch, mhm. Ja, Florian, guck genau hin, wie sich das reinsteht. Vielleicht sollte man doch Präsidenten keine Dokus sprechen lassen. Nee, beim Ernst, ich glaube, das läuft anders. Ich glaube, die Filmen und Filmen, Filmen, Filmen, die sammeln Material und die filmen und filmen und filmen. Mehr als sie brauchen, glaube ich. Glaube ich nämlich auch. Und nicht alles, was gefilmt wird, landet bei Netflix. Nein. Die nehmen das, packen es in den Schneideraum und sagen, so, ich denke dir was aus, tschüss, tschüss, fliegen wir. Ja, Skript, da steht ja am Ende immer written by. Und du denkst dir, wenn der jetzt nicht der Name des Bärs steht. Nature. Ja, okay, manchmal steht das auch dabei. Aber das ist das Ding. Tatsächlich muss ich sagen, ich habe meinen Glauben an Tierdokus in dem Moment wieder ein bisschen gefunden, als ich mal in einem Flugzeug, habe ich auch, glaube ich, schon ein paar Mal erzählt, Flugzeug die Bären-Doku gesehen habe, von einem Eisbären, der hatte zwei Kinder auf dem Rücken. Und die hingen ihm auf dem Rücken und haben sich immer so festgeklammert. Bärenkinder. Bärenkinder und der Bär läuft durch die Gegend. Braubären, Braunbären. Das sind für den Bärenbrüder. Ne, ne, ich hab, also, das sind bunte Gummibären. Und die, so, und, ne, es war tatsächlich kein Eisbär, jetzt hab ich die Bilder wieder im Kopf, Braunbär, Grizzly. Und der hatte Bärenkinder auf dem Rücken. Ja. Und dann läuft er durch die Gegend und man, ah, wie der sich um die Bären kümmert und bla bla bla. Und irgendwann harter Cut hat nur noch ein Bären auf dem Rücken. Und dann so ein der Bärenkinder auf dem Rücken. Und dann läuft er durch die Gegend und man, ah, wie der sich um die Bären kümmert und blablabla. Und irgendwann harter Cut, hat nur noch ein Bären auf dem Rücken.
Und dann so, ein der Bären hat er verloren.
Jetzt sucht er weiter es.
Und die so, wow, das zeigt ihr nicht, wie der den fucking Bären verloren hat. Aber anscheinend haben die Dokufilmer diesen Bären verfolgt mit zwei Kindern und eines Tages so, ah, wo ist er, wo ist er, what the fuck, nur noch ein Bär und die hatten einfach kein Material von dem Moment. Aber das finde ich aufrichtig. Ja, das fand ich auch aufrichtig, dass sie dann nicht mit so einer Teddybär-Puppe dann versucht haben, das irgendwie zu faken, war es ja oft genug. Nachgemacht, so ein Teddybären draufgeworfen, in der Hoffnung, dass er dann so im richtigen Winkel runterfällt und man das irgendwie behaupten kann. Nee, das finde ich richtig, dass man dann sagt, but the cameras were off. We have no footage whatsoever of the Pussy Bears. We will never know what took them. Was it the birds? Or was it the hot sunshine? Or the vast, the vast vastness of life and existence. Okay, ah scheiße, die lachen schon nicht mehr, okay. Rein, so, ist natürlich ein bisschen schwer zu drehen, aber für den Sketch könnte man ja Schauspieler in Tierkostüme stecken, die dann, pass auf, pass auf, die dann im Wald sind und dann so tun, als wären sie Tiere und dann aber immer so, ah fuck, was war meine, sorry, Text, ich hab einen Bärenhunger. Text? Ich hab einen, ich hab einen,
aber ist da, sorry, fuck, fuck, okay.
Boah, ich hab einen, äh,
cool, was ist das? Text? Bärenhunger.
Text nochmal, ich stehe direkt neben dir.
Ich stehe direkt neben dir. Ich hab diese
Fellohren hier über meinen eigenen Ohren.
Weiss. Sorry, wirklich,
Quentin, ich kann das so nicht,
ich kann das so nicht fortsetzen.
Quentin, das geht nicht. Ich habe einen Bärenhunger.
Aber ich verstehe es nicht, weil als Bär ist jeder Hunger, ein Bärenhunger. Quentin, das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn. Kann ich ein anderes Tier Bärenhunger sagen? Weil das ist doch Unsinn, wenn ich als Bär das sage. Oder, sorry, ist gar niemand meiner Meinung. Wir machen Mittagspause. Das will ich jetzt auch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe lieben Grüße an die neuen Zwanziger,
den Podcast mit Stefan Schulz und Wolfgang Schmidt,
einen ganz, ganz tollen Essay jetzt gelesen,
über Netflix und was da alles so schiefläuft
und warum die Filme so schlecht sind.
Die haben den empfohlen, ja.
Genau, die haben den empfohlen.
Da bin ich noch nicht in der Folge. Ich spoiler nicht, ich spoiler ein bisschen. Aber es ist so irre, und da habe ich echt gedacht, dass wir leben in so einer Truman-Show-Welt, weil tatsächlich kam so nach und nach ein bisschen jetzt raus, Netflix hat ja mal versucht, also Netflix berüchtigterweise sagen dir ja nicht die Zahlen, wie viele Leute etwas gucken, die sagen nur, etwas läuft sehr gut und vermitteln für Aktionäre und Investoren das Gefühl, es läuft schon sehr gut. Da hatten die mal irgendwann so das Gefühl, sie mussten, wollten Werbung machen, also sie haben einen sehr günstigen Tarif und dafür war dann ein bisschen Werbung geschaltet. Und nach und nach sind alle Werbetreibenden abgesprungen. Und das haben dann so Journalisten beobachtet und gesagt, ah, vielleicht waren die Werbetreibenden nicht so überzeugt von den Zahlen, die Netflix anscheinend behauptet zu haben, vielleicht stimmt das gar nicht so übereinander. Und dann kam raus, dass zum Beispiel es den Leuten, die Serien machen, das Gefühl geben, dass sie etwas sehr Wichtiges, Relevantes, Beliebtes machen, was aber vielleicht gar nicht der Fall ist. Und wie sie das machen ist, auf den Weg zur Arbeit von Leuten, die Serien machen und Filme machen, plakatieren die die Poster. Das ist fantastisch. Das heißt, die Billboards von irgendwelchen Adam Sandler, Murder, Mystery, was auch immer Filmen, hängt dann nur bei den Leuten, die das machen, in der Nähe. Und dann habe ich gedacht, dass von How to Sell Drugs hingen halt in Köln-Ehrenfeld, wo wir die gemacht haben, sehr viele Poster davon. Und ich dachte, wow, alle gucken das. Und jetzt nach und nach kommt vielleicht raus, es ist niemand gesehen. Niemand hat die Serie gesehen. Aber das finde ich so irre. Nichts hat mehr Bedeutung, alles ist weird, wir leben in einer komischen Welt. Weil es geht nämlich nicht mehr um Inhalte, ist uns auch schon seit ein paar Jahren jetzt aufgefallen. Allerdings, ja, und wir versuchen uns ja auch anzupassen. Ja, aber geht es tatsächlich nicht mehr. Es geht nur noch um behauptete Minuten, die wollen, dass es im Hintergrund läuft, die wollen, dass man irgendwas guckt, es gibt diese Möglichkeit, dass man sagt, mach irgendwas an, es gibt so einen Button, watch anything,
und es ist nicht mal, was deinem Algorithmus entsprechend zu dir passt, darum geht es schon
gar nicht mehr. Also, was ja auch schon scheiße war, für Algorithmen zu produzieren, ist auch
schon nicht mehr der Fall. Jetzt wird einfach nur, guckt irgendwas.
Es ist einfach Bildschirmschulung. Es ist einfach, damit irgendwas sich bewegt auf dem Bildschirm.
Weil die Guckminuten klingt sehr viel und ist eine gute Art, um Investoren das Gefühl zu geben, was wir hier machen, hat mega Relevanz und ist mega erfolgreich, wenn in Wahrheit ist eigentlich nur, alles ist nur Pixel-Gewitter, fand ich einen guten Begriff. Ich fand das sehr spannend, aber es ist irgendwie gruselig auch. Es ist irgendwie gruselig. Ich habe mal irgendwann gehört, dass ab drei Minuten gilt es als geguckt. So was ja auch krass ist, weil irgendwie drei Minuten passiert auch nichts. Das ist genau wie beim Buch, wo du die Widmung vorblätterst und dann sagst du, zack, Buch gelesen, war ein gutes Buch. Zauberberg, mega. Also vor allem der Anfang halt mit den, also die, halt so die Auflage und so und Copyright und so. Ja genau, genau. Wie meinst du? Ja, wo der Berg dann so sagt so, wow, krass ist. Wie meinst du, wie der Berg sagt? Nee, Zauerberg ist voll krass. Das Buch ist richtig krass. Und am Ende hat niemand das Buch gelesen? Niemand. Es gibt bestimmt Bücher, die einfach noch nie jemand gelesen hat. Niemand. Keine einzige Person. Was glaubst du, ist die grösste Diskrepanz von jemandem, der mal ... Also, glaubst du, jemand hat mal eine literarische Abhandlung geschrieben, irgendwas Wissenschaftliches, etwas untersucht an den Buddenbrooks zum Beispiel, aber Buddenbrooks nicht gelesen. Also, was ist die grösste nicht gelesen, über etwas geredet Diskrepanz? Irgendwo gibt es das bestimmt. Ja, ja. Das ist mal ein literaturwissenschaftlicher Ansatz, der mich interessiert. Über welche Bücher lügen Menschen, dass sie sie gelesen haben? Da hätte ich Bock drauf. Bibel kriegt man ja so mit nebenbei. Da kriegt man ja so die Geschichten nur ein bisschen mit. Aber ich glaube, Bodenbruchs ist ganz weit oben. Oder Effibris oder so, da einfach, da hast du, da siehst du kein Land. Ja? Ja,
glaube ich schon. Bei Effie Bries
siehst du kein Land, Florentin
will. Schreib das nicht auf dem
Buchrücken, sorry, schreib das, ich möchte
es zurückziehen, schreib das nicht auf dem Buchrücken,
dass ich das gesagt habe. Bei Effie Bries siehst
du kein Land.
Siehst du kein weites Land. Kein Land.
So, möchte ich zurückgezogen
haben. Kann man dagegen vorgehen, wenn jemand dein Zitat auf dem Buchschreibt? Ja, natürlich. Ja? Natürlich. Du musst ja gar nicht daraus stehen. Recht an der eigenen Meinung. Man muss nicht dazu stehen, was man gesagt hat, sagst du? Doch, man sollte dazu stehen, was man gesagt hat. Ich dachte gerade, ich hätte dich erwischt. Aber man kann dich nicht einfach nur, weil du was gesagt hast, draufschreiben. Also wenn du jetzt zu deinem privaten Freund gehst und sagst, hey privater Freund,
nur wie man halt mit Freunden redet, und sagst so, ey dein Buch ist echt gut,
kann der nicht, wenn er ein Buch schreibt, draufschreiben, Florentin will, ey dein Buch.
Ey dein Buch ist echt gut.
Und man darf auch nicht Leute finden, die so klingen, so heißen.
Also dass du jetzt irgendwie Günther Jauch jemanden findest, der heißt Günther Jauch und dann gibst du dem 100 Euro für beste Buch, das ich hier gelesen habe, ist die richtige Antwort. Wie viele Marcel Reich-Ranitzkis kann es geben? Richtig. Ja, okay, da wird es schon schwierig. Der Name ist viel wert. Du kannst ja dein Kind absichtlich so nennen, um das dann zu verkaufen. Marcel Reich-Ranitzki-Tietze, also als Vorname. Ja, ja, genau. Alles Vorname. Kannst du machen, du kannst so viel Geld verdienen. Und dann verkaufe ich meinen Sohn Marcel Reich-Ranicki zusammengeschrieben auch. Genau. Tieze ganz klein. Auch klein geschrieben. Ganz klein. Ist das so? Kann man Sonderzeichen, gross und klein schreiben? Du kannst mit Fonds kannst du alles machen. Mit Fonds? Fonds kannst du alles machen. Du meinst eher was wie ETFs. Nein, Fonds. Fonds. France. Vive la France. Fonds. Nee, nee, Fonds. Kannst du alles machen. Helvetica, Times New Roman, bist du komplett frei. Es gibt keine Regeln. Keine Regeln. Kannst du wirklich machen, was du willst. Da gab es ja das Buch von O.J. Simpson. O.J. Simpson soll ja angeblich Leute ermordet haben, hat das wahrscheinlich auch, wurde aber freigesprochen im Prozess. Riesending, riesenamerikanisches Drama. Weiss ich, warum er es hilft, als ob er davon noch nie gehört hat. Für einfach, um alle ins Boot zu holen. So, und dann sollte der ein Buch schreiben, weil er Geld gebraucht hat, und es wurde aber von anderen Leuten verlegt, die gegen ihn einen Prozess gewonnen haben, und die wollten ihm nichts Gutes. Und dann hat er ein Buch geschrieben, das hieß If I Did It, wo er darüber schreibt, wie er es denn gemacht hätte, den Mord. Das If war ganz, ganz, ganz, genau, klein.
Und dann, bei der Ver ganz, ganz, groß.
Und dann bei der Veröffentlichung stand ganz winzig
klein If und dann nur I did it.
O.J. Simpson. So, und da
hatten die dann quasi ihren aussergerichtlichen
Erfolg mit der Veröffentlichung von diesem Buch.
Und da habe ich gelernt,
mit Typo kannst du alles machen.
Mit Typo gibt's
keine Gesetze.
So, aber jetzt können wir uns ja Bücher ausdenken, die sich sehr gut verkaufen. Ja. Irgendwie so, I love for Adolf Hitler to be dead. Okay, ja. Und dann einfach nur I love Hitler. I love Adolf Hitlers Art.
Und dann aber das Art ganz klein und nur, ja, kannst du machen. Und dann I Love Adolf Hitlers ganz gross. All of them. Ja, aber sowas ... Das ist ja gut. Ja, das ist ja Betrug. Dann bist du nett. Nicht mit Typo. Du bist eins von Netflix. Typo ist raus. Du bist kurz von Netflix. Nee, nee, nee, hör auf jetzt. Ich will auch mal eine Serie für Netflix schreiben. Ich will auch mal so richtig was ergeben. Ich möchte jetzt plakatieren für Leute. Plakate haben Macht. Ich möchte jetzt Leute verarschen, weil jetzt wo ich weiss, ich dachte auch immer, wenn man plakatiert, hat man gar nicht so viel Einfluss darauf, wo genau plakatiert wird. Anscheinend hat man sehr viel Einfluss darauf, wo genau plakatiert wird. Das heißt, ihr zu Hause, jeder von euch kann die Strasse, das genaue Billboard auswählen, wo eure, könnt ihr bei Photoshop machen, kann jeder selber machen, eine gewisse Werbung drauf machen können. Das heißt, wir können vom Head-Zentrum, Headquarters von Gästeliste Geisterbahn Podcast-Ufo-Werbung machen. Jetzt denke ich natürlich im Jahre 2025 mit Internetwerbung. Geht das denn auch auf Internetwerbung? Also, dass ich wirklich auf konkrete Personen targete, dass ich sage, Stefan Tietze soll den ganzen Tag Werbung zu meinem neuen Buch, zu meinem neuen Erotik-Fantasy-Roman Die Ritter der Fick-Runde kriegen, damit er sich denkt, verdammt, dieser Drecks Florentin David Pascal Will ist so erfolgreich mit seinem Roman Meiner stinkt ab, um dich wirklich in den Wahnsinn zu treiben. Was ich am Witzsten mache, ist, dass ich dir gesagt habe, nenn es die Ficker der Tafelrunde. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, die Ritter der Fickrunde. Das war schon im Druck, das war schon in der Typo und das hatte alles schon so seinen Sinn. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ja, peinlich. Nee, das ist Kunst. Du bist einfach nur Brüder verklemmt. Ich meine auch der Airport Crush, mein, mein Erotik-Fantasy-Roman. Fantasy, ja, mit Vamp-to-See, mit Vampiren auf einem Flugzeug. Es ist immer so viel drin bei dir einfach. Das ist wie so eine Junior-Tüte, wo du dann auch noch mal die Fruchtstücke rausholst. Ich habe so viele Ideen, da kommt alles zusammen einfach, weißt du, weil man kann sich da nicht zügeln. Das ist zu viel auf einmal. Das ist super spannend. Das ist so unangenehm Salat. Die Welt, in der wir leben, ist so spannend. Ey, es gibt so viele Dinge, die man anfassen und in den Mund nehmen kann und einfach mal schauen, was also wirklich mal andere Sinne. Ihr habt das Gefühl, ich bin so auf Augen, ich glotze alles an, aber ich fasse es nicht an. Ich fühle es nicht, ich schmecke es nicht. So wirklich die wenigsten Dinge landen am Ende in meinem Mund. Warum eigentlich? Warum weiß ich nicht, wie ein Strassenstil schmeckt? Warum weiß ich nicht, wie so ein Kieselstein schmeckt, wie ein Blatt schmeckt einfach? Warum weiß ich nicht, wie das schmeckt? Ich bin so auf einen Sinn reduziert. Ich meine, ich finde immer, also richtig krass, wo wir sind, ich bin jetzt neues Jahr, neuer Hundeliebe, Hunde der Geruchssinn ist schon krass, weil wir als Menschen, wir sehen die Welt, wie sie ist, aber der Hund riecht die Welt, wie sie war. Der Hund hat zu jeder Zeit die gesamte Zeiteindrücke jedes Ortes vor der Nase. Glaubst du, wir haben ein anderes Zeitverständnis dahingehend, dass das Sehen unser bestimmender Sinn ist? Auf jeden Fall. Menschen haben im Verhältnis der Sinne ist das Sehen am besten ausgebildet. Sehen und Zeit hängen ja super miteinander zusammen, weil Zeit ja immer auch beobachten ist, zwischen zwei Ereignissen oder die Bewegung eines Ereignisses ist ja Zeit. Und es ist halt sofort.
Genau.
Etwas passiert und du siehst es sofort.
Aber Geruch dauert immer ein bisschen.
Genau. Und wenn ein bestimmender Sinn ein zeitlich unabhängiger ist, wie eigentlich nur das Riechen sein kann.
So, aber jetzt, was mich auch interessiert, also wir alle kennen natürlich Lichtgeschwindigkeit, Schallgeschwindigkeit.
Was ist mit der Geruchsgeschwindigkeit? Wie schnell ist Geruch? Und ist es unterschiedlich? Weil jeder kennt das natürlich, man ist unterwegs, der Darm meldet sich. So, klopft an und es gibt, wir müssen reden. Flatulenzen. So, der Darm sagt, pass auf. Ich weiß, was jetzt passiert, finden wir nicht schön.
Ich hab hier ... Finden dich auch nicht schön.
Nein, aber der Dame tritt ja erst mal relativ höflich in die rein und sagt, ich hab hier was vorliegen.
Magen und Darm, beide.
Genau, Magen und Darm.
Beide treten vorliegen.
Wir haben uns, wie so eine Intervention, wir haben uns hier zusammengeleitet.
Und pass auf.
Wir müssen, genau, wir haben uns beide überlegt, ich bin Margot Magen.
Okay.
Sorry, ich bin gerade im Kino, ich hab gerade echt nicht so mega viel Zeit, aber Herr Dahmen, Sie müssen sich auch vorstellen. Ja, genau, mein Name ist Dieter Dahmen und Entschuldigung für diese Störung jetzt an diesem unangenehmen Ort. Wie gesagt, gerade im Kino. Sorry, ich bin, muss es jetzt sein oder ist es? Ja, genau, sorry, es ist leider sehr wichtig, weil wir, genau, wir sagen, wie es ist, es geht jetzt los. Genau, also wir haben hier ein paar Szenarien vorbereitet. Alle Umschläge. Richtig, also wir hätten Szenario A, das wäre, wir bringen das Ganze hinter uns, die Sache ist vergessen. Genau, Szenario B, wir schieben es auf ein bisschen und das wird später zu Krämpfen führen. Ja, dann haben wir noch Szenario C, wir versuchen das Ganze so leise, wie es geht, über die Bühne zu bringen, wir können aber für nichts garantieren. Das heißt
auch, dass etwas
in die Hose gehen kann. Richtig, das ist
genau, die Frage ist natürlich nur,
wie viel Spielraum würden
sie uns da zusprechen?
Also wir können das Ganze alle
schleusen auf, oder
wir gucken, was wir machen können.
Und dann möchte ich dazu sagen, kurz als Stefan wieder, Achtung, nicht, dass wir durch den Hunder kommen, ich habe bis heute mir nicht gemerkt, welche Position die leiseste ist. Ja, ja. Ich habe das Gefühl, es ist auch nicht immer die gleiche Position, die leiseste. Nein, nein, nein. Manchmal ist ein schlimmer, schlimmer Furz ein so ein lautloses Windchen. Es ist ja auch ein altbekanntes Diktum, dass Geruch und Lautstärke diametral, also gegenseitig proportional gut untersucht auf jeden Fall. Und natürlich auch, klar, hat auch, also müssen wir auch drüber reden, natürlich, also vielleicht kann ich mich nochmal ganz kurz anmelden, ich bin nämlich für die Körperbehaarung zuständig und ich würde sagen, dass wir gerade im After-Bereich eine Situation vorherrschend haben, die, was Lautstärke angeht, stark begünstigt. Also wir haben hier wirklich es mit einer Kategorie C zu tun, es ist ein Date, Wir haben uns rasiert gegen meinen Willen. Wie gesagt, das ist nicht immer gut für die dermatologische Setup, auch für alles, was folgt. Das ist privat. Wie gesagt, ich bin nur in beratender Tätigkeit hier vorhanden. Ich will nur sagen, dass was die Lautstärke, Resonanz angeht, sind wir durchaus am oberen Limit angekommen.
Dann muss ich auch mich kurz zu Wort melden. Mein Name ist Schliessmuskel. Ich habe insgesamt nicht viele Optionen. Ich habe aus und an, also geschlossen und auf. Das sind meine beiden Zustände. Jetzt muss ich das unschöne Thema Öffnungsgeschwindigkeit ansprechen. Ich weiß, ich bin da alleine. Bitte, bitte sprich frei heraus. Ich bin der Meinung, dass die, aber vielleicht, wie gesagt, bin ich da auch biased, wie man neudeutsch sagt, je schneller ich aufmache, desto besser ist die Möglichkeit, höher ist die Möglichkeit, dass wir es leise vonstatten bekommen. Eine Wortmeldung? Hey Leute, ich find's ja ganz geil, was ihr hier labert, ja. Wer sind Sie, wie stellen Sie sich vor? Aber ich sag mal so, ich bin die Jeans, ja, und ich sag mal so, ihr müsst euch um überhaupt gar nichts Sorgen machen, ja, ich hab das Ding unter Kontrolle. Ich sag mal so, mir ist noch keiner rausgerutscht, ja, und ich sag mal so, ihr könnt hier euer Larifari gern abhalten. Oh, das tut mir leid, Entschuldigung. Oh Gott. Oh Gott. Wie schnell breitet es sich aus? Ja, jetzt ist es auch bei uns angekommen. Oh, meine Augen! Meine Augen brennen! So, aber da kennt ja natürlich auch jeder natürlich das Epizentrum. Das Epizentrum, es geschieht, der Vorfall ist passé und man holt Luft und denkt sich, ach, also das Röntgengerät schlägt erstmal nicht an. Not great, not terrible. 3,6 Sievers, so alles okay, es ist in Ordnung, aber dann merkst du, oh mein Messgerät war vielleicht noch nicht ganz auf die aktuellen Umstände bereit.
Vor allem, wer bin ich, also je nach Raumzirkulation, also ich will mich kurz die Raum, nee, aber wer bin ich, das genaue Resultat zu bewerten, was ich da gerade vom Stapel gelassen habe? Ja. Weil ich mit meiner Nase bin ja nicht unbedingt, wie gesagt, je nach Luftzirkulation kannst du ja gar nicht bewerten, was du angerichtet hast. Es gibt mit Sicherheit Momente, wo wir dachten, oh, glimpflich davongekommen. Ja, ja. Aber eigentlich hat man wirklich die Hölle ausgelöst. Aber warum solltest du da vorbelastet sein? Also, ich verstehe bei Körpergeruch, Schweißgeruch, dass man das selber nicht gut wahrnimmt. Weil du es ja den ganzen Tag konstant riechst, du bist abgehärtet.
Luft zu, du bist weg von dir.
Es wird weg von dir in eine andere Menschengruppe, neben dir.
Moment, stopp, reden wir hier von Qualität oder von Quantität?
Qualität.
Weil du kannst ja auch nur wenig von einem intensiven Geruch wahrnehmen.
Jetzt kommen wir in die Thermodynamik.
Moment, oder?
Immer wieder kommst du mit deinem thermodynamischen Dreck.
Vielen Dank. von einem intensiven Geruch wahrnehmen. Jetzt kommen wir in die Thermodynamik. Moment, oder? Immer wieder kommst du mit deinem thermodynamischen Dreck. Es wird in eine gewisse Menge Gas freigesetzt. Du stellst die Frage, die Badewannenfrage. Wie breitet sich Wärme in der Wanne aus? Okay, weiter? Ja, und da habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass ich da keine Antwort zu habe. Okay. Aber du stellst immer wieder diese Fragen. Nein, also ich frage mich, also sagen wir mal, du kannst ja, sagen wir mal, du hast einen Wein, du hast einen guten Wein und einen schlechten Wein. So, und jetzt kannst du ja von beiden Weinen unterschiedlich viel trinken, aber auch wenn du vom guten Wein nur einen kleinen Schluck trinkst, kannst du ihn als guten Wein feststellen.
Klar, du hast wahrscheinlich eine bessere
Chance, eine gute Einschätzung
zu machen, wenn du mehr trinkst, aber
die Menge und die
Qualität sind unterschiedliche Dinge.
Kleiner Schluck. Aber wenn
du jetzt von Luftzügen redest,
redest du von der Menge, die
in der Nase ankommt. Aber um die geht's ja gar nicht bei der Bewertung der Intensität. Nein, bei mir geht es nur um Standort. Deine Nase ist nicht unbedingt das ausschlaggebende Messinstrument, weil der Standort möglicherweise nicht der richtige ist. Aber der Standort hat doch nur was mit der Menge zu tun, nicht
mit der Qualität des Gases.
Wir sind ja in einem komplexen, das ist ja Chaos-Theorie,
wir sind in einem komplexen System.
Da passieren ja ganz viele Dinge,
unter anderem ein Luftzug, ein stetiger
Luftzug von links nach rechts. Meine
Nase bewerte das ganze
Happening ja anders als die Nase
meines rechten Nebenmannes.
Unabhängig von
allen Grössen, Stärken,
Intensität, alles egal.
Du meinst, dass duken, Intensität, alles egal.
Du meinst, dass wenn jetzt quasi der ...
Also du bist in einer Badewanne und Wein wird freigegeben,
dass der bei dir in einem anderen Mischverhältnis ankommt
und du damit auch die Qualität nicht mehr richtig ...
Wenn du jetzt die Badewanne aufmachst, dann müssten wir da von einer Strömung.
Ja, okay, dann denk von mir aus eine Strömung. Gegenstromanlage in Badewanne, ja. Ich glaube, das ist, also klar, für die Ich glaube, du kannst schon, angenommen, du hast ein Stinkekäse, sagen wir mal, und da ist ein kleines Stück auf deinemer. Kannst du trotzdem an dem riechen und sagen, nee, lieber nicht. Den finde ich nicht gut. Voll. So, auch wenn es ganz wenig ist. Gehe ich mit. Und das ist der Fall, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel bei dir ein Luftstoss und das meiste wegweht und du nur wenig davon abkriegst, kannst du trotzdem sagen, ach du meine Güte, das war ein Riesending, ich muss schnell weg.
Klar, wenn du den kompletten Kilo Käse auf deinem Teller hast, dann ist es für dich schlimmer, aber nur weil Qualität und Qualität zusammenkommen. Die Qualität selber kannst du auch von einem kleinen Stück bewerten. Also wenn man in so einer, in so einem Luftkanal, wo so Formel-1-Wagen getestet werden sind. Und wir sitzen aber jetzt vertikal. Okay. Wir sitzen, also der Strom kommt von links. Und ich habe das Käse-Stück bei mir. Und in welche Richtung schaust du? Schaust du, also bläst dir der Wind ins Gesicht oder in den Rücken? Nee, nee, kommt von links. Von links? Von links. Und deswegen meine ich, von links kommt der Wind. Ich sitze, also ich habe ein Käsesstück vor mir auf dem Teller. Und du sitzt rechts von mir. Kriegst du die volle Breitseite dieses Käses ab. Ja. Ich kriege mehr Menge. Ich kriege mehr Menge, aber qualitativ doch nicht anders. Ja, da gebe ich dir auch schon wieder recht. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist natürlich die Frage, aber es ist schwer zu sagen, weil natürlich auch die Mischverhältnisse anders sind. Je weniger du mengentechnisch abkriegst, desto mehr Fremdgerüche mischen sich ja auch rein in deinen Luftzug. Und da hast du ja andere Dinge drin, weil du riechst ja nicht nur einen Teil der Luft, sondern alles zusammen. Genau. Und dann ist es vielleicht auch qualitativ anders. Aber warum müssen wir uns all diese Fragen stellen? Warum ist nicht eine Wissenschaft dran? Ich höre nur von Licht, Licht, Licht, Brechung hier. Scheiß doch mal drauf. Mal Gerüche, wie schnell breiten die sich aus? Was sind da Mischverhältnisse? Was kann jeder tun? Und jetzt komme ich, Albert Nasenstein, um die Ecke und sage, Geruch ist relativ. Ja, das sagst du zu jedem Thema, fucking Nasenstein, egal was wir machen. Geruch ist relativ. Ja, aber du hast seit drei Tagen nicht geduscht und das ist halt auch einfach objektiv. Mitbewohnerin A, Mitbewohnerin B. Ich heiße Bianca, erst mal. Geruch ist relativ. Wenn ich stärker einatme, bleibe ich jünger. Okay, wir haben jetzt aber wirklich entschlossen, dich aus der WG rauszuschauen. Was? Weil es funktioniert für uns einfach nicht und das ist dann für uns einfach nicht relativ. Ich bin in deiner Zeitrechnung 200 Jahre alt. Ja, das ist einfach ... Albert, wir kommen so nicht weiter. Und ich weiß auch, dass ich für dich nur 12 Jahre alt bin. Geruch, Dilatation. Wenn du mir ständig sagst, dass du mich als zwölfjähriges Kind siehst, das funktioniert für mich langfristig auch nicht so. Nach meinen Berechnungen. Weil das ist einfach ... Weil so viel Geruch wie ich einen ... Nein, Albert. Wenn du dich meinem Zimmer näherst, jede Stunde in meinem Zimmer sind sieben Stunden in Koblenz. Nein, okay. So, und deswegen würden Hunde hier sitzen. Und würden Hunde hier sitzen, würden die sich denken, was labern die? Digga, was labern die? Was labern die? So, weil für die ist es ja selbstverständlich. Die wissen genau, welcher Geruch, ja, unterschiedliche Gerüche breiten sich unterschiedlich schnell aus. D, was soll jeder? Was labern die? So, und die wissen ganz genau, wie sie das zu urteilen haben, weil die es kennen. Die müssen es auch kennen, da rauscht jemand am Fahrrad bei denen vorbei und die denken sich, wer ist es, wer ist es, wer ist es, ah, der ist es. Weil die kriegen das erst ein paar Sekunden später mit. Aber dann, wenn again, Ursache, Wirkungszusammenhänge werden nicht verstanden von Hunden. Da fährt jemand vorbei und die sagen nichts, weil sie das nicht verstehen. Ein Geruch kommt an und sie denken, oh krass, was ist denn jetzt gerade passiert, wo für uns klar ist, ah, Fahrradfahrer wahrscheinlich gestunken. Ja, ihr merkt es, es drehen sich die Rollen ein bisschen um bei uns. Also ich bin jetzt, ich schätze Hunde mehr, du weniger. Nein, ich liebe Hunde, ich liebe Hunde, ich bin ein Riesenfan und es hat mein Leben viel besser gemacht. Ihr Lieben da draußen, wir wünschen euch ganz, ganz viel Spaß. Nehmt wirklich die Umwelt auch mal mit anderen
Sinnen wahr. Benna, da ist es komplett zu.
Ja, nicht immer nur Glotz, Glotz, Glotz.
Ihr seid ja eher ohrenlastig.
Hallo,
ich höre Dinge.
Ja, nein, fühlen, schmecken,
riechen, sägen,
ja, auch mal reingehen in die anderen Seite.
Jetzt genug Öhrchen, mehr andere Sinne.
Ja, dabei viel Spaß, wir sehen uns nächste und riechen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Wenn es heisst, tschüss, bevor es erhebt.
Brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr